la question du cannabis par exemple
est-ce que vous considérez qu'il faut
légaliser je pense que aujourd'hui ça me
paraît pas être la bonne voie malgré
l'action très volontaire des forces de
l'ordre le trafic de drogue dans notre
pays est un gros sujet de préoccupation
et qu'on a des jeunes et des moins
jeunes qui tombent dans des
consommations de produits dont ils sont
dépendants qui peuvent leur détruire la
santé l'idée de ceux qui vous disent
légalisant le cannabis c'est de dire
voilà on crée une bulle dans lesquelles
ça serait légal et ça éviterait de
passer
je pense que ça n'est pas démontré mais
c'est des débats qu'on peut avoir alors
qui est d'accord avec la
ministrement d'accord il faut surtout
pas dépénaliser le cannabis à usage
ludique le cannabis ça rend dépendant le
cannabis est addictif c'est extrêmement
dangereux donc pour moi c'est absolument
pas récréatif c'est un danger pour la
société je suis entièrement d'accord
avec elle ne pas c'est très dangereux
ouais et il y a beaucoup de choses qui
sont très dangereuses et dont tout le
monde se fout on nous vend des
cigarettes on nous vend de l'alcool on
nous on nous vend des aliments qui sont
dégueulasses pour notre corps dans
l'indifférence générale et là pour le
cannabis on est offusqué sachant que
dans certains pays ça fonctionne plutôt
pas trop mal en Hollande ça fonctionne
pas si mal la consommation augmente
beaucoup plus dans les pays où ça a été
légalisé et en plus les gens vont se
tourner vers d'autres droits parce que
justement il y a l'interdit et donc ils
veulent plus aller vers le cannabis ils
vont vers les drogues dures tu vois les
statistiques de garder leur ligne de
conduite alors beaucoup d'hésitation
Amsterdam notamment
certains États américains ça fait
apparaître une augmentation du nombre de
consommateurs post légalisation du
cannabis dans tous ces pays c'est les
trafics ce qui peut entraîner un usage
d'autres produits stupéfiants maintenant
on fait baisser les trafic d'autres
drogues directement pas forcément
parce que comme ils le font de façon
comme ensuite il y a des plans c'est à
dire c'est les gouvernements qui
décident eux-mêmes de cultiver ça fait
baisser moi j'ai j'ai noté un chiffre je
sais plus c'était 20 milliards de
dollars ce qu'on a enlevé aux
organisations criminelles par exemple en
Uruguay - 20 milliards ils ont pris
des choses pardon ils seront
mais la légaliser c'est quand même
envoyer un signal de c'est pas si grave
c'est ok c'est cool de prendre du
cannabis c'est quand même des drogues
qui détruisent des vies et je suis
d'accord et ben il faut le faire aussi
il faut il faudrait interdire des appels
Hugo combien de morts de l'alcool et de
la cigarette en France il y a combien de
ventes au volant quand tu fais une
cigarette en revanche le cannabis ça ça
réduit ta perception des distances et il
y a beaucoup d'accidents cannabis pas
quand tu fumes une cigarette c'est bien
la cigarette mais il y a pas de mort
parce que tu fumes une cigarette sur la
route je veux dire en vérité même si
c'est pas légalisé le cannabis est
emmène en fumer vraiment t'en trouve
partout moi mes enfants on leur propose
du cannabis à la sortie des écoles et
ils sont pas dans des cités donc
mais c'est parce que je suis en train de
tenir je viens de te dire comment
trouver partout
je te dis je te dis simplement que ça se
trouve facilement donc c'est pas parce
que tu vas légaliser le cannabis qui
vont fumer plus en revanche non
ça se passe pas comme ça dans tous les
statistiques
mais moi c'est pas du tout les sondages
que j'ai vu moi j'ai vu qu'on vous fasse
ça faisait réduire justement
de la prohibition bah c'était pareil il
y avait effectivement de temps de la
prohibition des espèces de trafic qui a
plu aujourd'hui puisque l'alcool et la
Galilée est prise en compte par le
gouvernement quand on voit tous les
médicaments tous les médicaments qui
sont dangereux et qui sont en vente
libre par exemple pour les jeunes moi je
suis très inquiète pour ça pour mes
enfants je suis d'accord
donc une sorte de fatalité
s luttons luttons contre ceux qui en
vente n'acceptons pas cette fatalité
insensée qui tue les enfants pour
l'instant la lutte justement contre les
stupéfiants ça fonctionne pas non plus
regarde les prix qui arrive pas à
rentrer dans les quartiers bah oui non
mais c'est vrai
la France la deuxième pays consommateur
de cannabis
et deuxième ouais deuxième c'est
beaucoup grâce à notre ami Doc Gynéco
cannabis c'est cool
on avait laissé l'appareil du passage
c'est ainsi la troisième cause de
déclenchement en appartusimocard il
induit les artérites des membres
inférieurs plus précocement que celle
provoquées par le tabac les talons
vasculaire cérébraux
sur le cannabis c'est pas bon pour la
santé on est en train de te dire je dis
que le tabac nous donnant une liste
qu'on sait très bien on n'a pas dit que
c'était bien les Marseillais là il y a
combien de
morts là et quand tu vois de l'alcool tu
peux faire une liste tout aussi
importante que ce que tu es en train de
faire merci cerveau c'est pas pareil
mais pour d'autres choses il y a pas que
le cerveau dans l'avion plus petit mais
non mais ceux qui vont qui proposent
aujourd'hui à tes enfants enfin en tout
cas elle a sorti des écoles du cannabis
proposeront si c'est légalisé de la
coque et des choses beaucoup plus gras
tu penses que les tu penses bien sûr que
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui il va parler
tu penses que quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui
gagne grâce au cannabis 1000 euros par
jour va gentiment parce que c'est
légalisé allez se faire gagner 1000
euros par mois ouvriers bien sûr que non
il a trouvé d'autres pratiques beaucoup
plus graves et beaucoup plus de beaucoup
plus des drogues beaucoup plus violents
je me dis que d'abord j'aimerais bien
qu'on sorte là et qu'en 15 jours là moi
je dis moi je dis oui je suis d'accord
avec elle parce que on peut pas
légaliser parce que le cannabis tu t'en
fume beaucoup beaucoup moi je connais
plein de gens qui fument ils vont au
boulot ils conduisent ils font des trucs
voilà
même mes enfants on sort là en 15
minutes trouve-moi du cannabis pas de
problème
si je sors je te jure que je trouve pas
de cannabis en 15 minutes 20 minutes 30
minutes j'en trouve pas parfois
si tu le légalises demain je vais au
tabac en 5 minutes je t'en trouve et si
j'ai envie de fumer 3 pattes et que je
prends à 44 tonnes et que j'écrase une
voiture et que j'ai cramé une voiture
s'il y a ta fille dans la voiture tu vas
dire s'il est pas fumé de cannabis
peut-être que
c'est comme l'alcool c'est la
vérités des réseaux de de de trafiquants
de stupéfiant
c'est la prohibition
les deux là vous êtes malade mais vous
rendez pas compte
tous les pays tous les pays en débattre
Gilles on n'est pas des fous furieux
parce que on est pas en train de dire
que c'est extraordinaire
on essaie d'ouvrir le débat en se posant
les bonnes questions comme le font plein
de pays et il y en a qui reviennent pas
en arrière je suis désolé
raison il y a aussi le cannabis
thérapeutique ça existe aussi
c'est n'importe quoi arrêtez on enfume
pas qu'est-ce que tu racontes toi faites
du prosélytes cannabis c'est scandaleux
non mais c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs
Elisabeth borne justement en préambule
elle dit on se pose on se pose toujours
la question voilà on le débat revient on
revient systématiquement parce que
effectivement on se pose la question de
savoir ce que ça pourrait donner